عباره الذوق العام ملغومه يمكن تفسيرها
باكثر من معنا ولا يوجد تعريف ثابت لها
عباره متغيره المكان والزمان بل تخضع
لرغبات ومزاج مطبق القانون وهذه كارثه بحق
حريه وحقوق الانسان هذه باختصار بعض
التعليقات على بيان قرار جديد من وزاره
الداخليه العراقيه الذي اعلنت فيها عن
انشاء منصه خدمه بلغ الابلاغ عن المحتويات
الاعلاميه المنشوره في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي البلاغات التي ذكرها البيان
تتضمن اي اساء للذوق العام او الرسائل
السلبيه واخذش الحياء وما يزعزع الاستقرار
المجتمعين البعض ايد الخطوه اخرون
اعتبروها مفاهيم عامه قد تقيد حق الراي
وحريه التعبير من العراق نتابع تفاصيل
اكثر مع زينب المشاط معها القصه
[موسيقى]
الكترونيه تطلقها وزاره الداخليه العراقيه
للابلاغي عن المحتوى الهابطي والموسيقى او
ما يبث رسائل مجتمعيه سلبيات او تلك
الخارجيه للحياه جعله من الصاج التواصل
والمواقع الاعلاميه وصناعها تحت مجهر
الرقابه بهدف الحفاظ على الزائقه العامه
للمجتمع العراقي
[موسيقى]
المبادره تعد ايجابيه بالنسبه للكثيرين
بالتزامني مع انتشار من يطلق عليهم بصناع
المحتوى الفارغ وترويج مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لمواد توصف بالاسفافي والابتذال
حتى ان المعارضين لهذا النوع من المحتويات
صاروا يقعونا بفخ التسويق لها من خلال
انتقالها
اخرى تعبر عن قلقها من تلك المنصه يعتقد
البعض انها لم تضع معايير واضحه في وصف
المحتوى الخادش والموسيقى تستخدم من قبل
البعض لتصفيه حسابات الشخصيه من خلال
البلاغات الكيديه او قد تتخذها الجهات
المعنيه وسيله للطبيق على الحريات بدريعه
بس ما لا يلائم المجتمع زينب صباح العربيه
بغداد
[موسيقى]
للاسف اللي متصدر العراقي اليوم المحتوى
السيء اللي ما نحب كمجتمع عراقي
يتصدر للدور
اليوم على وزاره الداخليه عن احلى معاها
بهذا
التوجه العام ولكن لا يطغى على توجه
الحريات فاحنا دايسين صوره وصوت وليش ما
اعرف يعني هي اكيد ايضا موجهه انت مجتمع
انا مو مو ادعي مجتمع محافظ لا لا بالعكس
تكون حريه بس تكون حريه بالتزام حريه
محترمه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من بغداد على الشمر الخبير في
الامن السيبراني ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وعلي سعد الناقد الاجتماعي اهلا بكما معنا
نبدا بالاول في دقيقه نفهم رايكم مع وضد
ولماذا سيد علي الشمري لماذا انتم ضد هكذا
قانون لتحديد الذوق العام في العراق في
دقيقه لو سمحت
قناه العربيه بدايه احنا نسيب الاجراءات
وزاره الداخليه بقضيه المنصه الكترونيه
وبجهود وزير الداخليه عبد الامير الشمري
لكن لدينا بعض الامور التقنيه الذي
مهمه جدا في معالجه الامور التقنيه في
المنصه الكترونيه المنصه الكترونيه فيها
مشاكل المشكله الاولى هي انه رفع ملف اقصى
رفع ملف هو 20 ميجا 20 ميجا لا تكفي في
حاله انه اردنا فيديو خاصه فيديوهات
اليوتيوب او فيديوهات الدكتور اضافه الى
ذلك في حاله انه اضافه رابط منشور هذا
الرابط الرابط المنشور ممكن الشخص الذي
يسيء او الذي يعني تكون فيها عبارات خارجه
للحياه ممكن مسح المنشور وبالتالي ان هذا
الشخص
ده من المفترض ان تكون هنالك فيديو
فيديوهات وهذه الفيديوهات يكون حجمها كبير
وليس 20 ميجا 20 ميجا لا تكفي للاسف اضافه
الى ذلك عدم وجود دعم تقنيه دعم التقني في
التواصل مع وزاره الداخليه او في التواصل
مع المنصه المنصه بلخ هذه وجهه
اسمحوا لنا انكم باسماء العائله يعني فقط
هتنقع في لغه المسمى نفسه علي وعلي استاذ
سعد اليوم نريد ان نعرف وجهه نظرك فيما
يتعلق به منصه بلغ لماذا انت مع منصه لكي
نفهم الصوره العامه
تمام مبدئيا صباح الخير عليك
واخيرا اييه
صارت هذه المنصه بعد مناشدات يعني بعد ما
تاذى ذوق العام بسبب صناعه المحتوى او ما
يسمى المحتوى
اعتقد وزاره الداخليه هي من سوى هذه
المناسبه تبلغ
رات الحفاظ على الذوق العام رانه تعرف انه
شنو اللي بيدخل للبيت العراقي باعتبار
حاليا ماكو بيت لا يخلو من المراه اللي
همم تقريبا اغلب الاوقاتهم على الموقع
التواصل تيك توك انستغرام فيسبوك
طبعا حاولنا بيها
نشرنا على امل انه تصير لانه اللي بده
يشوفه حاليا بالصابرين احنا المواقع
للعالم الفئه اللي احنا مريدها تطلع واللي
ما اعرف ليش عندهم متابعين اساسا بسبب علم
عمليات
طيب السيد علي الشمري سعد نعود له طب علي
الشمري انا حسب ما فهمت منك انه مشكلتك مع
القرار هي مشكلت مشاكل تقنيه متعلقه
بالمنصه وليست مشكله مبدا اللي هي الجهات
الابلاغ عن اي مخالفات الذوق العام لو
توضح
موضوع موضوع
المخالفات لحد الان ال ال المنصه لم يتم
الاعلان عن طريق انه كيف نبلغ على المنصه
كيف الشخص عندما يريد ان يرى محتوى سيء ان
يبلغ على هذه المنصه للاسف انه لحد المنصه
لم يتم الاعلان عليها بشكل واضح وذلك عن
طريق انه اقامه فيديو هذا الفيديو يشرح
كيف كيف نبلغ على هذه المنصه وكيف استخدمه
هذه منصه وايضا
المنصه كيف افرق بين المحتوى الهابط
والمحتوى الذي يفيد مجتمعنا العراقي هذه
الموضوع جدا المهم اضافه الى هذه الموضوع
عقوبه يعني افتهمت انه وزاره الداخليه
ومعروفيه هي جهه تنفيذيه همم الموضوع
هيكون عن طريق جهود من الاستخبارات او
جهود من وزاره الداخليه اقامه قضايا موضوع
التعاون القضائيه هتكون تستغرق مده طويله
اضافه الى ذلك موضوع التسويف موضوع الدعاء
لهذا انه يحتاج انه تكون اجراءات رائعه
صناع المحتوى فدهذاذا انه نفضل احنا عن
طريق هذه الاجراءات انه وضحوا لنا كل هذه
الامور احنا دائما مع حريه الراي مع حريه
التعب وهذه الامور المفروض توضح ما هي
العقوبات كيف ستكون الاجراءات متى سيتم
العمل بهذه المنصه لان دائما احنا مشكلتنا
في العراق انه نعمل من الصاج لكن عندما
اطلاقها لا
نقوم بعمليه تحسينها وتطوير المنصه هاي
المشكله طبعا في العراق ما شاء الله لدينا
كثير من الصاج لكن عمليه التطبيق وتحسين
وتحسين هذا المنصه لا يتم تحسين اساسا
نظره استاذ علي يعني بدات كلامك وكان
الموضوع فيه فرج انه واخيرا صار في منصه
للابلاغ عن ما تعتبره وفق رؤيتك يعني لكن
اليوم انا تعتقد انه من حق اي شخص ان يكون
له صفحه شخصيه باسمه وبالتالي الشخص الاخر
المقابل هو له الحريه وله الحق اذا يريد
ان يتابعه لا يتابعه حتى يعمل بلوك يرتاح
اقول يعني ما راح تكون من الفيديوهات اللي
خاصه وهي الصفحه تكون موجوده بس بهذه
الصفحه
يعني احتمالات وصفحات اخرى راحت
هاي الفيديوهات او مثلا نظام الاكسبلور
موجود بالانستغرام او الفيسبوك اليوتيوب
الفيديو الرائج فراح يطلع هذه الفيديوهات
قدامي وانا ما اريدها اساسا بنفس الوقت
اكغي عالم بدها تعاني بسبب هذا الموضوع
مو لانهم عندهم اطفال لا هم خايفين على
نظره العالم للعراق بسبب السوشل ميديا 70
75% من وقت صار عباره
اعلى من العراق ايضا تكون من ناحيه
ايجابيه كثير جميله يعني خصوصا يتم تصوير
الصوره الايجابيه والجانب المشرق للعراق
ليش ما اقوي هذا الموضوع لايجابي وانهي
السلبي ليش انه احاول اوازن شوفي هذا
الموضوع ما بيحريه نهائيا همم اني اقولهم
مسؤول عن كلمتها هذا الموضوع ما بيحريه
لانه هذا الشيء يؤثر على الذوق العام كلمه
خالي شايل الحياه
والى اخره وهذا الموضوع
كامل بعدين هي وزاره الداخليه لا تحاسب
الناس مثلا على سبيل المثال همم سوء
استخدام زي العسكري زي العسكريه المفروض
خلاص المؤسسه عسكريه داخليه
بالعراق اكون زي يستخدمون الزي العسكري
اثناء مثلا الحفلات التخرج الخاصه مولي
بالكليه العسكريه
بجلسات تصوير
بطلعات عاديه شخص انه بس مجرد ما ياخذ
سياره عاليه همم طبعا للوالده ويشتري اي
زي عسكري من اي مكان ويطلع على اساس انه
هو تابع لمؤسسه عسكريه هذا الموضوع هم
اللي يحاربوه ده يحاربون ال همم
يحاربون الاسفار هم ما قصد انهم لا تعال
انت احنا نريد كلاش اوف كلانس
ومن اول الناس اللي طلبته همم باي لقاء
العفوا اي لقاء انا بدي اطلع ماشي انت
تقول يابا انه لازم يكون اكبر رقابه من
وزاره الداخليه على هذا الموضوع لانه بعده
وصل لحد همم
المشكله الثانيه
كل صناع المحتوى حاليا بالعراق
مخطوطين احنا شلون نقول مخلوطين كلهم بجهه
واحده للعيش سوشيال ميديا فلذلك ماكو فصل
يعني الزين راح وين الموزين
هذا الموضوع اللي بياثر على السنه المحتوى
حتى الايجابي ليش قلتي انهم اقسم بالله
ياثر عليه من كثرته فاحنا لازم هذه المنصه
يعني
فرج يعني هلال
تحياتي الى اللواء سعد معا وتحياتي الى
الاخ علي طبعا بالنسبه نحنا الموضوع المهم
هو كيف كيف يقيم المحتوى كيف تقييم
المحتوى يعني ممكن هالسعاني امتلك في
الانستغرام
549,000 متابع ممكن انه اطلب من اصدقائي
ومتابعيني انه يقومون بالدخول الى المدرسه
والابلاغ عن اي محتوى انني او ما احب هذا
المحتوى فكيف يتم التقييم موضوع التقييم
جدا هل هناك لجنه خاصه من قبل ومن قبل
وزاره الداخليه ما هذه اللجنه منهم اعضاء
اللجنه هذه الامور جدا مهمه انا الاجتهاد
من الخامات
انه هناك سيتم يعني الاتجاه الى القضاء
وبعد القضاء انه سيتم اتخاذ اجراءات يعني
وزاره الداخليه تنفيذ لهذا انه موضوع
القضاء مرات يعني بالقضاء يكون هناك
اضافه الى ذلك احنا ساعدنا بعد صناعه
المحتوى الفاش انه يخضعون الى ال يعني
تكون هناك دعاوي قضائيه وبعض الدعاوي
القضائيه يتم الوصول الى ان هناك تنتهي
القضيه بدفع كفاله مبلغ بسيط مالي بسيط
هذا انه نحتاج اضافه الى ذلك عندي ملاحظ
ملاحظه ملاحظه اخرى حول المنصه عفوا انه
هو هو تمكين تمكين ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه هم هم دائما
يتعرضون الى التنمر لهذا انه نحتاج انه
نعمل نعمل في المنصه الى تكبير الخط اضافه
الى ذلك تنفيذ كل المهام عن طريق لوحه
المفاتي لو احتياجات الخاصه دائما يعني
يتعرضون الى الى التنمر اضافه نقطه نقطه
مهمه لنرى لنرى منصات في دول الخليج
العربي
التطور التكنولوجي يعني مثلا ههه
تمتلك منصه اكثر منصه اكثر اللي هي محتوى
محتوى مميز ورائع نتمنى ان نصل الى الى
هكذا من الصاج وهكذا امور يعني همم حلمي
كان انه اقدم فقره صباحيه في اي برنامج
سواء كان عراقي او عربي شكرا
جزيلا لكم